(logo whooshing)
- I mean this!
We have to start talking
about sacrifices for 1% lifes!
Like if you're gonna make your dream,
if you wanna be in
fucking the 2K video game,
if you wanna be friends
with LeBron and Melo,
if you wanna be sneaker deal,
you need to eat some fucking bullshit!
(smooth jazz music)
Hey, guys!
It's Gary Vaynerchuk
and I'm doing my podcast
with two very handsome
and accomplished gentlemen today.
We decided not to do AskGaryVee in live
because we're gonna record this
before a ridiculously awesome announcement
that they're gonna drop at some
point during this interview
that I think, knowing my audience,
a ridiculous amount of you
are going to watch and engage with.
And so without further ado,
I'd love for you two to
introduce yourselves,
maybe share the mic a little bit
if you can.
- You can start.
- And tell everybody who's listening,
what you do, and what
you're about and who you are
and then we'll just start to chat.
- Cool.
Yes, my name's Chris Brickley.
I'm a NBA trainer.
I train--
- Chris, I don't know how this happened.
I always love how like I say I'm not
gonna interrupt and then one second.
- That's okay.
- But I don't know,
but this is how my life works.
The fact that you are so
ingrained in basketball
and your last name has brick in it.
- [Chris] I know people.
- How that hasn't hit
me until this moment,
that is the best shit.
- That's funny.
You read the comments, people,
they'll be saying that stuff.
- [Gary] Yeah, go ahead.
- I never thought about it
till you brought that up.
- [Gary] Wait, right?
- Oh man, it's real.
- But I hear people call
him Brick all the time.
I remember--
- So how does someone to
listen to you over basketball?
You have Brick in your last name.
People be saying that!
- You're literally the most negative thing
about a shot, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Happens all the time, but yeah,
so I was a director of player development
with the Knicks for four seasons.
That kinda got my foot in
the door with the NBA stuff
and now I train bunch of NBA guys,
own a clothing line called Color Blind,
and Black-Ops is an umbrealla
that we do the training under.
This is my manager.
- Alex Koblenz.
I work with a bunch of players,
Trae Young, Kevin Knox.
Chris, we focus generally on
their digital side of stuff
but with Chris, we do
everything off the court.
- Got it.
So the players and their digital,
you're not necessarily
their certified agent.
- [Alex] No, definitely not an agent.
- You're doing the marketing stuff.
- Yes, we work with Kevin--
- So with Trae, for example,
as somebody who's super deep now into,
my number one thing on Earth right now,
literally I can't make people believe it.
By the way, let me hedge it here.
I believe old basketball cards
are ridiculously great
long-term investment,
Olajuwon, Barkley rookies way back.
Lou, come in here and open the safe!
I wanna show them my Lew
Alcindor rookie cards.
- I got a bunch from my dad.
- But on some short-term shit,
and I don't know when the market
called the next 18 to 24 months,
and then it might collapse.
But for the next 18 to 24 months,
rookie cards are the best fit--
- Panini cards?
- What's that?
- What are those?
Are those Panini?
- These are Panini.
Get the Lew Alcindor rookie cards.
- This thing, the way--
- That's just sitting there?
- It's the only cards in that safe?
- Yeah, you're looking in it.
Yeah, there's nothing
but cards in that safe.
- [Chris] Yeah, it really is.
- Stock certificates?
- Wow, autographed?
- Jackie Robinson?
- Rookie card, 1948 leaf.
- [Alex] There it is.
- Wow!
- 10 Gs, what?
- You pass these around like this?
- Well, I mean, for you two!
- [Lou] There's another
behind that one too.
- Wow!
- This is fire.
- That's the real one.
You got the real ones.
Yeah, that's Kareem's fucking rookie.
- It's amazing that you have this.
- That was one of your
initial hustles with cards?
- That's right, I'm literally going full,
My current hustles are
sports cards and wine.
I'm literally living my 1994 life again.
- That's dope.
- Crazy.
25th anniversary tour, baby!
What?
(laughs)
- [Alex] That's life.
- Anyway, so got it.
So you do marketing stuff
and you do marketing for him?
- Yup.
- That's awesome.
- He's changed my life as
far as for the making--
- Talk about that.
Actually, you know what?
Back to hey, I wanna make sure
people know about your show,
and I wanna talk about basketball culture.
There's a ton of general
shit I wanna talk about
but actually knowing how
many entrepreneurs are here,
and personal brands and influencers,
hearing somebody who saying
that he changed my life,
we hear nothing but horror stories
of like, ugh, I hired this fucking person,
they took 20%, they did
dog shit, it fucking sucks.
You just said changed my life.
Take the mic and like--
- 100% changed my life.
- Why?
That's for everybody out there
who's got a little something going,
followers, a little
Fame, Netflix celebrity,
or fucking Instagram this and that,
and thinking about manager.
Why did he change your life?
- Everything was all over the place.
I thought I could just
do my DMs and emails,
contact these companies and--
- Get deals!
- Yeah.
And so in a year he's gotten me,
I'm the first trainer ever to be,
have a real sneaker deal,
I've got an NBA player sneaker deal,
I'm in NBA 2k.
I'm the first trainer ever to
have my own character in 2k.
- That's fucking crazy.
- But next year, he's gonna
have a scene in the game.
- So basically everyone in the world
that plays a video game--
- You've been making him
the most famous trainer by a long time--
- You have to train with me which is cool.
They have my tattoos on there.
- That was a nightmare, the tattoos?
- [Lou] Yeah, it's been a thing right now.
- It's a huge thing.
- Oh, the IP?
- [Lou] Oh, the artists are.
- The artists are suing 2k.
It's left and right,
so they had to do this
super complex, yeah.
- This is where art, this is where people
try to do, artists,
tattoo artists out there,
own, I'm gonna say something right now.
I haven't heard about this
only 'cause I knew some stuff
cover up the Hulu thing
with Damian Lillard.
If artists are trying to sue for their,
it's their art on people's body
when then it goes into
games or movies and stuff,
it's a really interesting thing.
If you go down that route,
they're gonna blur it out.
Cool, now what?
How'd you get put on in the first place?
- [Chris] Facts.
- I think also there was
other issues 'cause there's--
- So I want people to steal all my shit,
take all my content, make money.
You know how many people
run Gary Vee accounts
on YouTube pre-roll and
make money on my shit?
Do you know how many people
strip all my content,
set up a separate YouTube
account that they own,
and run ads against my
shit and make money?
A lot.
You know who's the happiest of it?
Me.
I'm getting the exposure!
Keep the pennies, I'll take the dollars!
- Yeah.
You like that one, Chase?
- That should be a T-shirt right there.
- [Gary] That's a good one, right?
- You enjoyed that one, right?
Keep the pennies, Tyler.
All right, go ahead.
- Yeah, so he's done that Red Bull deal.
He just gotten me all these deals that--
- He's a full-time professional!
- [Chris] I couldn't get myself.
- You, ironically, as a trainer
and understands how many jump shots
one has to take to be good at it,
on the business side,
try to do the shit that
us grub players think,
oh yeah, well, I shoot
sometimes and I should be good.
- [Chris] Yeah, it wasn't happening.
- It's the reps!
- For sure.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- Yeah, he's done, and then I
have a new training facility,
just basically--
- Where is that?
- 360, 44th and 3rd,
so I helped design it.
It's this beautiful
state-of-the-art basketball
training facility.
- Let's get right to the
elephant in the room for me
in a good way which is the fuck happened
and why and when when all of a sudden
everyone just started
talking about this gym
that the fucking legit fucking players,
during the off-season,
wearing funny ass clothes.
So much of culture--
- [Chris] It's like a fashion show.
- Yeah, like the hoodie shit,
Lebron's crazy fucking
hiked up shorts and shit.
Like, like, how the fuck did that happen?
What was that?
And for everybody who's
listening right now,
frame it up because I think
a lot of people know about it
'cause they've seen the clips
but they haven't made the
association to your world.
- Yeah, how did it happen?
- [Gary] So you have this gym.
- In my mind, I was doing these workouts,
I've always been in the fashion.
I have tattoos or whatever,
whatever the fashion thing,
I'm always been in the music.
Chris Brown was like one of
my best friends years ago
and that opened the gates--
- Is that right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You guys were friends as kids?
- No.
- From where?
- Probably from 24 to 28.
- Why?
- I was like someone--
- How'd you guys?
- We connected.
I was with Melo training in LA.
He just got out of jail
and we met at a party
and he's like, yo, let's work out.
So I worked him out.
He kinda just--
- Loved it?
- Yeah, and we became real close
and that's kinda how today I'm so,
I went in Travis Scott's tour,
taught him how to shoot for
two months during the winter.
That was crazy!
- It's so funny.
We're living such a fucking
similar life, you and I,
just in different skillsets,
in the same way that all the thick people
that I think are the coolest wanna come
and get a skill for me in business,
all the people that you
think are the coolest
want to get better basketball from you!
- Yeah, it's crazy.
- I think I wanna get better!
I have the worst jump
shot of anybody I know!
- [Lou] I don't know!
- No, no, I'm effective with it
but from a form standpoint,
it's completely dismantled!
- Tyler was just telling
us you had a good jumper.
- He did, before you walked in.
- [Lou] No, you also
set up your hand right.
- I don't think so.
- [Lou] You gon' told him--
- We need to do a session.
- No, no, it's incredibly awkward.
It's some Shawn Marion shit.
It looks ridiculous and goes
in way more than it should
but nowhere close to
anything that's respectable.
- We need to do a session.
Would you be down for that?
- Okay, we're going to.
I actually have been thinking a lot about,
I've been working out now
for the last four years
and I'm starting to hit fatigue.
I've gained some weight and
I've lost a little of my way
and I think it's just boredom of the thing
and I'm like, maybe I need to fight.
Lately, I've been thinking
about maybe I should fight,
maybe I should work out to actually fight.
I'm like you know, you know,
I might as well learn how to fight, right?
'Cause at this point with
what's going on my life,
that's probably a good skill set,
whether it's A, as you
get more fame and known,
something weird could go
down and somebody gets crazy,
and B, as you get more known,
you might just wanna challenge
somebody else that's cool
and beat 'em up and have a viral video.
I just wanna beat up somebody.
And like you know, so that might be--
- Offer that risk of getting beat up.
- Yeah, but I'm not scared of losing.
I would probably be the most
excited if there was a clip
of me getting knocked the
fuck out by Dave East.
- [Alex] Oh my god!
- I probably, when I wake up the next day,
I'd probably be like,
yo, this is at least eight million views.
- I could imagine.
- When you're not worried about losing,
you know, scared money.
When you're not worried about losing,
that's what I love about
fucking UFC fighters.
They all are gonna lose.
It's the nature of the sport.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- It's not like boxing where
there's enough padding.
Where skill, It's just too raw.
Anyway, nonetheless, so
you guys became friends.
- Yeah.
The question, how'd I become.
Yeah, I don't know, I just,
New York City's helped.
New York City's helped,
being obsessed with the game has helped,
not caring about money
for the first eight years
of trainings helped,
being broke and--
- Stop.
I mean, you know this about me
so I gotta use other examples
besides me saying or me living it.
Tell the kids how much
you, today, with all,
90% of my audience wants to
be doing what you're doing.
Tell them how much actually
eating shit for eight years
for real, for real and
explain your shit eating,
because when you're not
worried about money,
you're eating shit.
People always, like me,
it was easy for you, Gary.
Your dad gave you a liquor store.
I'm like, you don't know my story.
I built my dad's business for him.
I left at 34.
Do you think I would
have started VaynerMedia
at 34 years old in somebody else's
ghetto fucking conference room
if I had all sorts of money?
I built a business for
somebody else and at 34
by never paying myself more than $100,000.
I had no money.
When I tell everybody be
patient, it's easy, I did it.
I was 34 and I had no money.
I made a video yesterday.
If you're 26, I wanna remind you
that I was ringing up people at a register
in a liquor store when I was your age.
Tell me about the eight years.
- Yeah.
Shit, it actually kinda gives me,
I don't even like talking about it
because I don't want a kid to see it
and be like, damn, I don't think I could.
Yeah, I was just dead broke.
I had zero money.
I would do workouts for free.
I was always, my account
was always in the negative.
People didn't think that I would be
able to coach the NBA guys.
I slept in Ole Miss
Practice Facility with rats
for a whole year getting
$8,000 for the whole season.
Yeah, I lived in New York
and every debt you
could think of possible,
people thought that everything was good
'cause I'm working on
NBA guys, but it wasn't.
I had zero--
- Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in New Hampshire.
- Okay, so right.
So the people from back home, like oh,
he went to the big city.
Oh shit is that him with Carmelo?
And they think it's great but--
- And I didn't charge NBA guys at first.
I just wanted to get my--
- Why?
- I was worried that off the bat, why,
'cause I was worried that
if I was gonna charge 'em,
that they were gonna be like,
they weren't gonna wanna do it
for I don't know what--
- Period!
- I don't know why--
- But, wait, period!
But wait, for everybody who's listening
and saying this is bullshit.
Some people got mad at me recently.
You're telling everybody
do something for free.
I'm like, I'm not telling
anybody to do anything.
I'm telling everybody one
of the ways to get in.
You're looking at two people
who did things for free that got in!
You wanna charge?
Charge!
You think some noble
act is being put on you.
Like you should, people are mad!
They're like, you're undermining
the price of something.
I'm like, no, I'm not!
The market is the market.
Who the fuck do you think I am?
You think my little point
of view in the world
impacts designers and
artists and trainers?
Get the fuck outta here.
I'm giving you one of the ways in!
- Subway and ramen noodles.
- When nobody knows who the fuck you are,
they don't wanna pay you.
- Facts.
Facts.
I literally would go months
literally eating ramen noodles
and subway every single meal.
- 'Cause it's easy as
fuck to do that at 20!
The way you're saying it right now,
and everybody's like you said
don't, that's easy in the 20s!
- It kinda sucks sometimes.
- It sucks sometimes but it's
not the worst in your 20s!
- No, no.
- If you're gonna make your dream,
if you wanna be in
fucking the 2K video game,
if you wanna be friends
with LeBron and Melo,
if you wanna be in a sneaker deal,
you need to eat some fucking
bullshit in your 20s,
which oh, by the way, you eat anyway.
You'd much rather eat
fucking shit in your 20s
to live the life you're
living now than to waste it.
Do you know how many people complain
and are living in a studio
apartment in Bushwick
and buying $5 coffees?
You're making the wrong fucking decision.
You don't want it that bad.
You're not willing to sacrifice.
You wanna make pretend
you're winning along the way.
- There are a few times I'd
be, a player would fly me out,
say we'd be in Miami and we have to meet
at University of Miami gym
and I would have to take
a Uber meet the player
and that that Uber ride--
- Put you in the negative?
- Yeah, and then I didn't
have a way to get back, facts.
Life happened numerous
times, stuff like that.
- So how'd you get back?
Be like, hey, I'm coming with you!
- No, ah, shit.
I would have to make up
a story with the NBA guy.
- Yeah.
- I didn't want the NBA player
knowing I was broke either,
so I'd have to be like,
yo, I think I would say,
my Uber account was, I
would lie about my rating,
I couldn't get a Uber,
can you call me an Uber?
- Yo, that 2 1/2 star
rating, I need you, dawg!
(laughs)
- That's actually true.
- 'Cause I did that, man.
- Your rating.
(laughs)
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, you actually do have it.
'Cause you're not a nice guys, right?
- No, I am.
- I'm just kidding!
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- No, but I--
- My rating is through
the roof, by the way,
'cause I'm all charming
and shit in the back.
Plus, I was first.
- That's dope.
We're talking about that.
- Actually, actually--
- [Man] You have like 50 of 'em.
- Actually, where is it?
Where's AJ?
Shit, right there.
Have you ever seen this?
This is the one of the
great mistakes of my career.
Travis comes to New York
and he's like, yo, Gary,
I need you to take the
first Uber in New York
'cause I gotta test the service.
And I'm like, I gotta
go on this client call.
I'm like, yo, AJ, take it.
That is an email from Uber emailing AJ,
thanking him for being
the first ever person
to take an Uber in--
- That's wild.
- New York.
How crazy is that email?
- Yes, especially--
- What's it say?
What's it say?
What's it say for the podcast?
- It says, "Hey AJ, I wanted to say thanks
"for being our first ever
Uber rider in New York."
- Guys, do you know how lucky the world is
that AJ was the first
Uber rider and I wasn't?
'Cause AJ's super humble and quiet
and doesn't talk about shit.
If that was me, this story
would've been told today
for the 19,000th time this week!
- You also got a credit,
it says, for 10 bucks.
- You've got a contact
space that'll help you out.
- I know I might have
to actually post that.
- Today's a big Uber day.
- Today's a very interesting day for me.
- Wow yes.
- I mean I lost out on
lots but I made lots,
nobody's crying for me today.
- This is wow.
- So yes, so that's
that was your life when
did you, when did it turn to something
a little more sustainable, you got the job
at the Knicks?
- Yeah a little bit, yeah
for sure that helped.
My first year at the
Knicks I was an intern
so they were they don't pay anything
I was so I actually had to live with
the, that is funny I've
never probably said this--
- Good, I want some fucking scoops.
- Fuck it I'll say it.
Yeah so I live with the girl she was like
my girlfriend but I really didn't
really like her like that, I was just
living with her so I
could have a spot to live
it was in Jersey--
- People do that all the, that's what
every human does, there's
a lot of that going on.
- A whole year and is just
up because I just wanted
to be in basketball,
wanted to work so bad that
I would sacrifice my personal life
of spending time with her who and I didn't
even really love her maybe she might
have thought I did and then the next
year I got a promotion
and actually broke up
with her it's fucked up.
- Listen everybody's listening--
- That's fucked up man, that's fucked--
- Do you know what's funny?
They think it's fucked up but if you
really talk real shit and humans don't
talk real shit, people make trades bro
people make trades, she might hear this
and instead of what everybody thinks
all her feelings are hurt, she'll be like
I fucked him.
That's real, that's real talk
look at all the guys, everyone's like,
Shaun's like stunned.
I'm obviously using the
most extreme way to say it
but she's maybe she loved that year
- Hmm.
- Maybe that's the best
year, I don't know maybe,
it's not maybe she's pissed
I don't know but humans make trades
and humans make sacrifices
and we don't talk truth in our society,
we don't talk about sex in our society,
we don't talk about money
in our society, you know?
- No, for sure.
- It's just the truth,
everybody listening, you could
judge all three girlfriends
I had in my 20s were there
because I didn't wanna
be lonely because I was working from
9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. every fucking day.
I wasn't dating I didn't go.
I worked every Friday and
Saturday night from 22 to 28
of my entire fucking life,
till 9:00 to 10:00 p.m.
and was tired after working
15 hours in a retail store
on my feet on the floor.
So now at 43 I can be like
ugh, right those girlfriends
were a utility for an
enablement for what I wanted.
I was nice to them we
had good relationships,
- Yeah, same here.
- I'm sure some of them are
pumped that they could walk
around and say they were my girlfriend
for a couple years now it's making
it even better for them
and more importantly
not even like that,
like low, like whatever
more that it was a it was a
fine time everybody's trying
to do the best they can and maybe I didn't
even I didn't fully
realize I was doing that--
- Mm-hmm.
- It's subconscious.
- Yeah it's true, that's
true, when I think back.
- It wasn't just like
your master plan was like,
you know, you know what I mean.
- Yeah.
- You realize it later.
- Mm-hmm.
- So for everybody who's judging
seven minutes ago fuck you, look
at your own fucking actions.
- Thanks, yeah so the Knicks and then,
I guess just recently just within
the past year so I
could tell I told my dad
he could retire, um,
because I could really
take care of I could start--
- Shit.
- Start doing stuff
with money and so yeah--
- Crazy, right?
- It took a long time people--
- It didn't take that long let's again--
- Yeah.
- I'm going very real
here there's something about us together
at this moment I'm gonna a lot
of real places no it did not take very
long, sounds like it was about eight
or nine, 10 years when you live a 100
fucking years that's not a big
percentage of your life.
If you actually told people
to eat shit for nine years
and it will highly likely result
in a lot more of what you're trying
to achieve not maybe everything that you
dreamed up and fucking yachts and shit
but a lot more than if you spent nine
years being half pregnant
living in the studio by yourself instead
of with a roommate drinking a $4 Blue
Bottle coffee in Bushwick instead
of making Maxwell House
motherfucker I mean
this we have to start talking about
sacrifices for 1% lifes you wanna
retire papa you have to drink shit
there's nobody retiring there papa
starting at zero in nine years that
drinks $4 coffee in Bushwick and that's
what I see from everybody
everybody's complaining.
Uh, it's hard takes forever I'm like
you're wasting money on dumb shit
you're not sacrificing for your actual
dream you want it to be easy all along
the way you still think it's fucking
high school and your parents
are taking care of you.
- Hmm.
- Soft, you guys are fucking soft.
- Well a $4 coffee is like
the easiest thing to cut
out right I mean--
- When and ready for this actually
it's a great opportunity I've been meaning
to clarify this I don't think people
who drink $4 coffee are
soft if they don't complain
almost all my advice actually
and it's not even advice,
'cause I actually don't think I'm
putting out advice I think I'm putting
out context of information that you need
to look at and decide what it means
for you that's my intent.
But the one clarification just
for everybody listening is
I don't think you're soft
if you drink $4 coffee.
I think you're soft if you
complain about your life
and drink $4 coffee.
If you complain that your
start you can't raise money
for your startup cool save your money
and you can start your own startup.
I drink $4 coffee but I'm
not complaining out here.
- Yeah.
- So I don't think it took long bro.
- And so now as you know--
- How old are you?
- 32, I'm older than you think.
- No you're not and I think because I can
do basic math of you being out of
school in eight years here's what I
think, I think I wish a lot more people
are really listening and paying
attention because I think 99% of the world
would eat shit for the first 10
years of their professional life to get
to 32, to be in a position to be doing
what they want lucratively,
but they're confused because
they didn't wanna put
in any days of sacrifice let alone three
thousand six hundred fifty of them.
- Mm-hmm, that's real.
- That's it that's actually my
current thesis on the whole fucking thing
lack of sacrifice,
lack of sacrifice for the
ambition that's coming
out of your mouth.
- Hmm.
- I don't want anybody to be
stressed I don't want any be upset,
I just want if you're telling me that you
wanna be the most famous basketball
trainer in the world,
that's rats in the gym that's walking--
- Hmm.
- Back 'cause you can't get an uber.
- That's not kinda sorta that's not
spending $4,000 on tickets on Coachella
I have no problem with Coachella
I've problem with you talking that shit
and not living it.
- Mm-hmm.
- I didn't say anything for the first 15
years of my life to anybody forget about
social media people well you didn't
have social media, I'm like I didn't talk
to anybody go talk to my high school
friends go talk to my college friends I
didn't even talk.
That's real.
- That is real.
- Cool, so now you're
32 and now shit changes
right--
- Yeah.
- Now you got to recalibrate--
- [Chris] For sure.
- Now you've actually done
the ridiculous dream that
you thought for yourself--
- Yeah but I still want that
still so much more in my mind I'm still
trying to still--
- [Gary] Like?
- Wake up every morning--
- [Gary] Instead of being--
- I'm not fulfilling--
- I believe that instead of bigger
and better right a bigger sneaker deal
a bigger instead of bigger better is there
anything completely left field that you
wanna accomplish not a no--
- No just keep this do what I'm doing
and just keep it going.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Yeah but yeah you're right so.
- No it's the funny thing I think a lot
about that lately for myself.
- [Alex] Well there is that one goal.
- Go ahead push it.
- [Chris] Oh yes so I want to be the first
trainer ever to make it being inducted
into the Basketball Hall of Fame,
there's coaches there's--
- Can we talk about the
Basketball Hall of Fame,
- [Chris] Yeah.
- Why is it such bullshit,
(laughs)
I know this is your dream
and you're gonna get it
I'll tell you why--
- [Chris] I gotta get.
- Why is it fucked up, why
is it to not have enough
rigor this is what every fans
problem is with the Hall of Fame right.
- Mm-hmm.
- Why is it so soft?
- Just talking about the basketball one?
- Yeah 'cause the other sports are good.
- [Alex] Right.
- Yeah that's true, do you
have a different take on that?
- No this is really, do you
have a hot take on this?
'cause I'm fuckin' pissed--
- [Chris] You always have takes on these.
- Listen I think Ben Wallace
is a fucking gangster, like--
- Is he in the hall of fame?
- You see what I'm
saying he's about to be.
- And Oakes not?
- I don't know I get
started, like, like listen.
- He manages Oakley too.
- Oakley is in the cultural Hall of Fame.
- Facts.
- But statistically Ben Wallace--
- Do you know I can't
like Oakley all the way,
and I fucking love him, I love him,
like all time but I can't
love him all the way.
- Why?
- Because he's friends with Jordan.
And I can't get it out of my system.
I could never fully go there I'm, I'm in
a very weird spot as a die-hard nineties
Knicks fan with Charles Oakley because I
love him with all my heart I probably
used him to feel tough in high school.
- Mm-hmm.
- He's all that he's been to the office
couple years ago I love him as a dude
I fucking love everything about him
but I can't fuck with him all the way.
- That's 'cause he's friends with Jordan.
- He's not friends with
Jordan he's fucking
Jordan's guy--
- He's close with Lebron also.
- I don't give a fuck I hate Jordan.
- He's right though he
is Jordan's guy, like--
- Yeah, but they were never--
- Guy, guy but not like hey I'm
friends, like--
- But that didn't impact anything--
- No, no I definitely I never
felt that I'm just talking life.
- He's a die-hard Knick fan too.
- Yeah.
- Do you know--
- I never for once thought
that that would be a reason
why because he was friends--
- Never me too,
me too, me too.
Especially now all these fuckers all
your boys all are friends I still don't
I hate when people oh they're
all friends now I'm like motherfucker,
I'm friends I've punched
my brother in the face
on a basketball court.
- Mm-hmm.
- Like I did something,
were you there when I
clothes lined Nate.
- [Lou] Yeah.
- I'll do anything on the
court so I don't think
friendship matters I'm talking just life,
I'm pissed about it anyway nonetheless I
really am I still can't deal with it,
god it's unbelievable how much I don't
respect Knick fans that have any love
towards Jordan I don't think you can be
in your 40s I think it could be
youngsters how old are you?
- 34.
- You might just be young and I think
you're young and I would say you're
if you're over 40 and I know by the way
I know I'm on an island all by my,
this is an island of one I've never worn
a pair of Jordans ever.
I hate a man I really do.
- You wear Nikes?
- Yeah I do
I'm wearing my Swiss but I wear Nikes
but I just I really dislike a man I
really really dislike a man I really
if I knew him personally, like that's
the one thing I've learned as my life has
changed oh this sucks now I know
these guys and now I can't hate them
the way I wanna hate them.
- Mm-hmm.
- You know I'm scared to meet Paul Pierce
'cause I love hating Paul Pierce this
week's been the best week.
- Mm-hmm.
- Paul Pierce getting shit on is the best
but I'm sure Paul's a good dude I
actually like a lot about what I know
about Paul, like rug--
- I've got a question for you.
- Go ahead.
- What's your take on when you,
when you because this
happened a few times,
you go your whole life
like you love someone,
look up to someone it could be any music
or whatever and when
you really get to know
em' you're let down, you're--
- Zero expectation of others.
- Mm-hmm.
- You will never, Chris
you'll never meet a happier
fucker on earth than me for one core
reason I have zero
expectations of human beings.
- Mm-hmm.
- Nobody has ever let me down I
never gave em' a chance.
- That's real.
- I don't have expectations my
employees don't let me down I'm paying
them you know how crazy that is?
- That is, that is.
- Now that's a weakness
as a manager because
it creates entitlement and I've had
to learn that over the last
25 years I've gotten better.
But it's crazy I've never
been I knew where you're going with
the question and usually
cut off what I know
the question is I'm trying to train
myself now it's a great question
and it's fuck man you wanna talk about
something I'd love to teach kids don't
expect just because somebody can drop 52
a night you think they're a nice person
just because somebody's got a fat booty
on the inner you think there's
sweetheart, like--
- We'll make a hit song.
- Don't have expectations.
- For sure.
- Right, on the flip
side my favorite thing
on life I was at Complex History doing
that sneaker show and the kid was like
really pumped that I was nice.
- [Lou] Yeah.
- You saw that?
- I love it on the flip on
the flip I love over-delivering when
people meet me in the wild.
- Mm-hmm.
- Yes so I was out--
- [Lou] I like that--
- You like that?
- That's funny way to put
it that's real that's funny.
- That was funny.
- [Lou] But you were posting
about it didn't they?
- Yeah.
- Yeah say what--
- No I just because for a number
of years I'm big on night walks so I get
one in the morning I walk a few miles--
- That's cool.
- And it's just nice my mental and I'm so
I used to do it--
- You can't do it anymore 'cause
you're known a little more?
- No I mean I might ah,
now when I do the walks
people would be like Brickley
and so normally when my mind
is in like in a, I'm in a weird state
if you catch me at 1:30 and I'm in my walk
and you say Brickley I might look
at you kind of crazy 'cause not because
of you looking at me because--
- You're painting pictures in your head.
- You're that deep--
- I got it.
- So, I went on Instagram and it got
to the point where I feel I was
freaking people out I pause I was
half joking half not like, if you
see me in the street in the middle of the
night and I looked at you like a ghost
like I apologize and as
I'm typing it someone--
- [Lou] Someone rolled up on you
- Someone comes up to me and I put it
on the camera thing but I yeah so yeah.
- I get it, you know what
this is gonna end up with?
You're gonna, you're gonna,
replace that with safer places my places
are the bathroom the shower
and airplanes where I do that.
The only places where I
know I can go into that
place are the places
where nobody can touch me.
- That's real.
- Mm-hmm.
Like it's unbelievable what the chemicals
in my body do when I go
into the bathroom when I go into a shower
or when a plane takes off and nobody's
boarding anymore and I'm in my spot it
is unbelievably important to the
operating system of who I am right now.
- That's real.
- [Lou] What about when you're in the gym?
- No, 'cause I fucking hate the gym
really like this is so much of my advice
now about what to do in life
is predicated on me being
a terrible student and hating the gym.
For everybody who's listening right now
that hates their job I understand I
don't understand hating your job 'cause
that was my great fortune of being
an entrepreneur, but I understand
the process of disliking something
that you have to do.
You know?
- Mm-hmm.
- Well I don't this is such a good show
what uh you got you have
something big coming out
and I wanna make sure we right hook that.
- For sure.
- Break it down.
- So, yeah, I got a show on ESPN
the ESPN network called Declared it's
me getting of NBA prospects ready
for the NBA Draft.
So, do on court, off court
get him ready from a skill standpoint
get em' ready mentally--
- How much, mental work do you do?
- Like, how much do you think from
your perspective that you're a nail
salon or a haircut I love nails,
what is it called and uh do you know?
- [Woman In Background] Manicures.
- Manicures.
- Manicures, but there was something else
remember they had a different term.
- [Lou] Technician.
- Technician, you're on fire bro.
- Yeah.
- Doesn't doesn't talk
for shit all of a sudden
he's drilling fucking,
you're in your zone bro.
I love hairdressers
and like, you know, manicurists and just
trainers and 'cause there's so much
there your therapist a lot of time.
- Everything, facts that's
everything it's just,
it's obviously I need to know
what I'm doing we get in the court but--
- We're gonna form but you're
also talking through there girl trouble
- Yes, you know, personal
anything you could think of after a bad
game get in to a fight
with their girlfriend,
you know family--
- Oh right, I remember you telling me
a story when we were
hanging once me sort of when
we were hanging once of being up
super late 'cause you
got to watch the tape
of a West Coast game and you're fucking
hittin' them up but they
and the some of these
fucking maniacs which I love about them
because that's why they're winners
and wanna fucking talk at 2:37--
- Yeah.
- In the morning of
like why, you know why,
why did they go three for 18
from the floor--
- And if I don't respond
I dropped the ball
they won't I could lose the trust--
- Who's the best, who's the best defender
in basketball right now in your opinion?
- Kawhi Leonard.
- Who's the next best?
Give me an unusual one
'cause I know you watch
a lot more shit than other people.
- [Chris] Yep.
- Give me up give me a
one that's not exactly--
- Patrick Beverly but that's pretty easy--
- That's easy too.
You got anything that's there were
the last couple years because I meet you
I know you might know--
- Tony Allen best too easy.
- Oh he was amazing.
- Yeah the great, he was amazing.
- Give me somebody that's I know
you might not be watching
film to the subject
being empathetic to all the things that
are going on your world--
- For sure.
- Give me one of the
last five to seven years
that you think it was that you were like
geez, you know what
this fucking guy's tough
that you just don't hear getting
headlines 'cause all three of those guys
I know as a casual I mean my football
knowledge is much deeper my basketball
knowledge--
- But I guess this could be oh
you the name is big but he doesn't get
the credit I actually think the best
on-ball defender in the NBA over
the past five years is Kevin Durant,
which no one would think that but--
- I fully understand that--
- Because he's seven feet tall--
- [Gary] The legs, the legs--
- And he moves like a
guard so he can guard
a point guard but then
he can guard a 5-man
'cause he's so long I
think people don't talk
about that Steven Naismith
doesn't talk about that.
- Well that doesn't get the that's not
what people wanna talk about.
How good of a defender,
I know like at this point
and he's still a baby that
there's less excitement
for him but like Frank on the Nick--
- Yes, super defender
- Yeah cool I'm happy it's funny
I, the Knicks have been so bad for so
long and my career took off my
career I worked all the time not
took off I was about to say that since I
was 22 I've been basically even that
great night 98 run I didn't fully I
was just working.
- Mm-hmm.
- So it was on the radio
in the liquor store.
Like it was hard, like it
wasn't 94 like, and football
is easy for me with the
Jets 'cause it's Sunday,
so I missed nothing--
- Mm-hmm.
- But basketball even next year when
the gardens going to be rocking--
- [Chris] Facts.
- I'm gonna be struggling to like really
be in it so but the last year or two you
know obviously we moved to Hudson Yards
here so I've got the crazy Knicks
seats and I'm trying to do more
and just look sports cards I mean these
deer and foxes I would have known
the deer and fox four years ago
in the league the way I
do now 'cause the cards
because this and I know the Knicks
are coming so my basketball game has
changed dramatically of being on it
in the last 18 months--
- And the players look up to you.
- Yeah you're right and that's been really
cool so really like eye test I'm
watching and I'm man Frank could be
just 'cause I remember how good
of a defender Derek Harper was there was
a time when I knew everything and so
that's what went through my mind
oh fuck he's a New Age Derek Harper--
- Mm-hmm he just can't stay healthy
- That I know you can't
stay healthy right?
- Can't stay healthy and
offensively he just--
- he's living it--
- Yeah, he is--
- He is a kid--
- Just needs to get his
confidence up yeah, yeah--
- He's only 19, right?
- Yeah, he's really
young, he's really young
defensively though--
- He would take on John
Collins in Atlanta,
as a player--
- Yes he's very good
actually so I actually
make a list when the seasons done
and I do like five, ten guys
that I'm I wanna try and I--
- Get them.
- Gotta train with him and he's on notice.
- So, he's what's that?
- He made a big job.
- He's on my list of sports card
investment that's that was the most
loaded fucking question, should I drop
five g's on John Collins rookie cards.
Let me see what Brick
fucking thinks of that one--
- Is that what the John Collins
Rookie card would go for?
- No, this is why this
is such a great game,
a John Collins rookie cards a couple bucks
but it could be 450 bucks if
I miss right about where I
think his game I go--
- How much is some of those,
like the ones we brought out--
- [Gary] Well the, those were
the the cream rookies are
8,000 a piece graded but these
Darren Fox ungraded are four bucks I
think so and then you can get
graded that's how they go in these
cases these these these Luka
rookies oh that's Kevin McHale this
that's Kevin McHale Rookie,
look at this look Luka rookie.
- Mm-hmm.
- To put him in those
cases it cost eight bucks,
that Luka rookies now 75
I bought I was telling
everybody on social media only 30 days
ago to buy him they were 40.
- Wow.
- It's an interesting game because I have
to be careful because I have to really
really start doing a better job contexting
and I think there's a really hot market
for the next two years I think people
should buy and sell new stuff--
- What about the game used stuff?
- You mean memorabilia, that's not my game
'cause there's no scale,
like I'm gonna buy I bought
a 187 Yanis rookie cards
in October for 150 apiece now there's 550.
- [Chris] Wow.
- And for all the sneaker hustler kids
I think there's money to me I think
there's a great two three-year run here
for these kids--
- But why is it two three years,
what's happening with the cards--
- I don't know what if
the economy collapses
the first thing that goes
our cards just like $4 coffee
you know, cards I mean nobody on earth
will buy them when you're scared of my
money so they go so supply and demand I
think demands about to build up
but there's a lot of these cards so if the
demand it's like in 90s the whole collapse
market of the cards that's why
it happened and you
got to be right lonzo's
have gone down dramatically in the last
two years so we could be sitting here 24
months ago I can be talking heavy about
this Lonzo thing kids could go out
and buy them, I don't know what it was
but let's say 75 and now
two years later they're 25.
- Mm-hmm.
- So--
- The hype around him was crazy
You know what's, what
do you think about him?
I actually think he's really good
actually--
- [Chris] I do.
- I think i yeah i actually
weirdly think he i actually that's
that's actually probably the guy I'm
most debating to go all-in on 'cause
I think he's super low right now
and everybody's mine
and I'm like here's my
thing actually this is actually crazy
why this is segwaying
in and talk to me about
the what is your macro take on people
Ben Simmons and Lonzo and people who,
like how much of a jump can
a, and I don't wanna even
put you on blast those guys though
I'm sure you'll be happy to talk.
- [Chris] Yeah it's all good.
- About it how much
better can a human get,
like what's the great story
in the last decade of somebody
changing their form or becoming
a ridiculously better jump shooter?
- That's a great question,
yeah I mean it's--
- Anything stand out, I'm
just trying to think--
- Ben Simmons isn't gonna just
all of a sudden be a knockdown shooter
it's not gonna happen but
it doesn't take away from--
- But he can do what LeBron
and Jordan did in their
careers which is exponentially get better.
- For sure he can keep getting
better in his shock and keep
getting better too but--
- What's scary is if he fucking,
if he got a solid jump shot--
- [Chris] For sure.
- He would become unbearable--
- Be a beast--
- He's a beast to begin with--
- He is, he would be that next for sure.
- I really him a lot too
as a kid I think man I
really want him to develop well I
don't actually 'cause fuck the Sixers but
he would be really that was for you Ruben
you'll never convert me
bro I'm a Knicks fan.
(Chris laughs)
- Fuck the Sixers,
and I have like, I love
JJ, like I love Ben,
I love, Tobias is the best as humans
but fuck them--
- The grit about that city's
dope though this to divide--
- Did we talk about this last time?
I can't believe you know,
you know this is my hottest take, right?
- [Lou] No.
- My hottest take is
Philly's the best city.
- It's dope, it's like a--
- Yeah like, New York's the best city
in the world--
- [Lou] Nah.
- But I wish New York felt like Philly
Philly's a little rugged, like
New York's become too
Manhattan's, too rich
it's super rich around here--
- You go to a game at the garden
and it's kind of like yeah--
- Rick is fancy you know when he's walking
the streets of those one Am's
he wouldn't have done that 30 years ago
no matter how tad a tough
he is like New York's soft.
- Facts--
- It's true--
- Yeah.
- I walk around comfortable
and cozy in New York now, 1978 be scared
fuckless out here.
- You know Philly has that--
- You know what the best part is?
The siren--
- [All] The siren.
- Listen in the background
right now in New York,
people and I were like fuck.
- Facts.
- Who's, who's the most
who's the top I wanna
finish this thought because I wanna
get this I know we have to probably wrap
up because I got family stuff the show
drops the show on ESPN--
- My goal is to change these kids lives
in a sense of the after this year's series
when the New York Knicks
have the 9th to the NBA
Draft they could pick player A or player
B but player A was real--
- Hold on, real quick now you're
making an amazing point I'll let you do
it again but the the shivers in my body
that just happened when you said Knicks
have the 9th pick like if
the Knicks don't have--
- Like 2025 he's talking about--
- I got it but then if that happens too
shivers, we should be really in a place
where 2024 should be good season
I'm expecting Pat Ewing is gonna be there.
- Mm-hmm.
- If this is to me it's
ironic I like the first three
players quite a bit I do think it's that
cut I'm gonna buy a lot of basketball
cards this season 'cause I think
it reminds me a little bit of that--
- [Chris] For sure.
- Darko was the one that didn't
work out but that rest that class got
crazy with Bosh and Wade
and LeBron and Melo--
- That was a crazy class--
- That was crazy class these first three
feel really legit--
- Mm-hmm, I'm with you.
- You know Barrett, you know who Barrett's
game reminds me of a lot
and I wanna ask somebody more educated
than me and just in a weird way
Michael Beasley RG Barrett's game
reminds me a lot of Michael Beasley
at this time in their careers
and obviously thinks about--
- [Chris] Yeah.
- I don't know mindsets and those work--
- No, no your right.
- [Gary] See where I'm going--
- He's like the guard version
of Beasley for sure.
- Kind of like that yeah
it's kind of interesting.
- He's definitely thinking
to be consensus third pick.
- I would.
- Yeah the thing it's still a like you
know whether the sons get it and they
need a point guard or whatever but just
have a talent you gave
me the you be three.
- What do you wanna wrap up with?
Anything that we didn't
cover, anything interesting?
- This has been great.
- You gonna start
collecting basketball cards.
- Yeah.
- Dude on a very serious
note I kind of want
you to I really think
there's something brewing.
- Is it only Panini and--
- Panini has the IP for
basketball, Topps for baseball
Panini for football, yeah.
- 'Cause baseball is the
place where you can make.
- Early baseball 'cause
you can get kids four years
away you can get crazy you can buy kids
for a $0.50 that go for fifty bucks
you get Fernando Tati's
Jr., but basketball--
- Has the minor league cards?
- The basket yeah they're in the yes they
sell them as minor league cards basketball
though is culture my hot take,
complete thesis my entire point
of view on this is sneaker kids are
gonna realize that's great that you want
to get the Travis Scott Jordans
but you're gonna get one pair and you'll
make your money but if you're right
about Darren Fox
you can go on eBay
and buy up a thousand
of them for four bucks
and then when he pops and they're fuckin'
39 that starts adding up and it's
liquid it's even--
- Is it liquid?
- It's liquid as fuck its
eBay you go to ebay right now its
liquid as fuck you go to completed items
like what sells what doesn't at what
price if though it's the most listen
I've loved cards is forever for me
to now be talking about them I listen I'm
starting to build a good enough track
record I don't talk about shit for fun I
don't like to show videos like I did
this morning about me passing on uber I
like to show the shit where I'm you
should buy Amazon and it explodes
basketball cards are gonna go through
the fucking roof for the next two years.
- Is Beckett still around?
- No, Beckett is actually,
you know what Beckett is now?
It's a grading company the
price guide is eBay right now.
Bro if you really know basketball,
like if you know,
you know the dude from
Toronto SEC what's it?
- Yeah, Siakam.
- If you know Siakam's
gonna pop last year,
which people did and you
bought them last year
compared to this year you made
a fuckload if you know the fucking kid in
Sacramento Shia gold what was his name?
- [Lou] Shai Gilgeous.
- Yeah--
- Yeah, from the Clippers.
- Alexander Shai yeah yeah I was just
talking to him actually yeah.
- If you know he's gonna pop next
'cause he looks he could be
one of the guys John Collins
could be one of the guys.
- For sure.
- Like if you have--
- It's like a finite time right
where it peaks and then.
- Well I mean you wanna hear
something crazy I bought
those 180g Yannis rookies--
- Well aside from those--
- Stick with this real
quick and I sold I sold 10
of them to just 'cause I was hey I
bought these for a hundred eighty I'm
some 10 of them for 300 a month ago
and now they're 550
like, the markets hot yes
there's a finite time there's by the way--
- But like Alexander, he
could have a good rookie year,
play good for a couple
of years and like, like
those cards you have in there--
- But those are iconic--
- What I'm saying is this
isn't like a buy and hold,
this is like a trade--
- This, well it's a buy and
hold if they become Kairi.
- [Alex] Sure.
- Like it depends on how great but it this
is what's great its merit-based it
depends on how good they become like--
- But just like their game used stuff
their value is one they're actually--
- Starts get in this mode
and he likes to starts to buy cards--
- No, go ahead, go ahead, I'm listening.
- He's about to start buying cards.
- I have a friend who's like heavily
into the game used stuff--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And the value of buying a Damian Lillard
now right in his game used
Portland trailblazers,
what is it gonna be worth 10 years from
now is probably not gonna
be what it's worth now.
- Ready for this that's exactly right
here's how it works.
You have to go top 1% if you're holding
forever what am I buying is LeBron
rookies I'm buying LeBron rookies
for 1,100 I'm buying
Kobe rookies for 1,100
I'm buying all time stuff and then I'm
speculating on under Pro Delillard
to me is actually still a speculation
because if he has one more contract
that's crazy not in Portland gets
on a super team and
wins a championship he's
under priced right now.
- Yeah, you're right.
- Like I'm trying to figure out
if Kimba or Kairi's coming to New York
and which rookie card I wanna buy
for the New York bump I'm not buying
Leonard rookie cards 'cause I think he's
too not culture and no matter how great
of a player he is it's not gonna be supply
and demand enough because people don't
fuck with him culturally enough.
- Facts.
- And there's nothing
wrong with that that's
amazing he's an awesome dude I love how
he leans into that and he's
self-deprecating I buy
Luca like crazy because--
- [Alex] Yeah, this is.
- Because he's white and if he's
Larry Bird there'll be a mark I think
this is just very basic shit.
- You're right.
- I know I'm trying to help kids
make some money out here so pay attention.
- Do you have a stake in Panini also?
- I have no stake in Panini.
- Yeah.
- I gotta go?
- [Lou] Yeah, we gotta go.
- You'll appreciate this I the number one
thing that would make me a ton of money
right now is if Pinterest went crazy
on the stock market how many times do you
think I've mentioned the word Pinterest
in my content in the last two years?
How many goose fucking egg,
the number one currency
in my life is being
historically correct not
any of the deals I'm in.
- That's deep.
- It's it's it's
it makes sense right?
- It does.
- Don't sell out I've
made money I don't need
to like you know, I'd love
to have a piece of panini.
I'm trying to do shit in sports card world
'cause I love it
here's why in 24 months I'm gonna be not
the only person talking about it in 24,
like I can't wait to be courtside
opening night Durant,
Kyrie, fucking the Zion,
I'm gonna have I'm know in my pockets--
- [Alex] Like open up a jacket
with all the cards in it.
- Bring 50 brookie cards and take a selfie
courtside with all the
cards and be like what?
- You get the jacket with
the case and you open it up.
- I'm making a prediction the way
kids now rich the kid puts fucking
a stack of cash to his ear I'm making
a prediction right now in 24 months people
can be flexing holding
fucking luca's like this.
- [Chris] Music videos.
- I mean, that's bold.
So we're gonna buy some
cards just in case--
- [Gary] It's a prediction.
- I can guarantee you
he's gonna do it now,
in 10 minutes.
- I'm just curious though, like what,
is there any--
- All right, we gotta go, see ya.
(hip hop music)